today I'd like to talk about why I use
Julia in my research which is almost
entirely scientific computing thanks
Eric for the great introduction and
congrats to everybody who want a book in
the raffle I'm really excited to be here
at PI data I know this is a conference
that's focused obviously from the name a
lot on Python but I hope to give sort of
a flavor of what Julia is about and kind
of suggested is something to try out in
an inclusive way and yeah just to
quickly summarize I work at the Flatiron
Institute we are hiring if anybody here
is a computational scientist or an open
source developer and interested check us
out but yeah so very quickly if you want
a one-minute answer for why I do physics
using Julia and then you want to go and
like get another burrito or something
the short version of the story is that
often in computational science research
we have this so-called two language
problem where you want to have one code
base that's like extremely performant
you've got like jillion MPI calls it's
running on a hundred thousand nodes
you've got the tight inner loops it's
like super optimized might have been
written in like Fortran 77 by your
advisors advisor you probably don't want
to try modifying that yourself and then
you say okay so this beautiful
performant code dumps some blob on to me
and I need to analyze that blob and make
a plot that I will put in my paper and
usually in the past and scientific
research you've had to use two different
languages to do both those things and in
some sense that's great because you're
using the correct tool for the problem
like you wouldn't try and drive in and
nail with the back of a screwdriver
necessarily you would use a hammer to do
that which is fine but it's also there
are costs associated with it because now
if you're trying to teach students or
you're trying to share your research
with collaborators you're sitting there
saying okay well now instead of just one
priming language you have to learn to
and you have to learn best practices for
both and you have to keep both code
bases in lockstep in case you change the
output format without telling anybody or
your adviser does that maybe we're one
of your collaborators and then all your
potting code does
where nobody knows why and you maybe
don't understand the original language
the code is written in so that's not
great and Julia kind of allows us to get
around this problem because it's very
easy to write code that's both very
performant easily parallelizable and
very readable for humans in general both
people who are computational science
experts and people who aren't and most
scientists aren't very very experienced
with coding so it's great if they can
read you know the code you wrote and
again I just want to start off this talk
on the foundation of saying that this
claim of Julia is not a claim that other
languages can't be both fast and
readable it's merely claim that Julia is
and I like using it and specifically it
works well for some of the problems I
want to solve which I'll go into it a
little bit the other thing of course is
that I actually have a deep romantic
attachment one based indexing unlike
many languages julia is one based and
it's great I'm never gonna get sick of
it it's just it's just so wonderful this
is a very common complaint and again it
takes all kinds but one based indexing
is great so there you go
and the another thing that's really
great about the julia community is that
there's a lot of people like the Python
community from very different sort of
walks of life people with all sorts of
different experience but many people are
very eager to share what they know and
learn what other people know and there's
really sort of a great cross-pollination
of techniques and areas of expertise
that's a really great way to both like
learn new things and improve the
research that we're doing okay so like I
said in the title I do quantum physics
so quick question who here knows what
condensed matter physics is put your
hand up not many people so I should
probably explain what this is before I
just roll in being like hey guys anybody
quantum magnets let's go so again it's
matter physics is kind of a I don't
wanna say obscure because it's actually
the biggest subfield of physics but it's
maybe something that doesn't have as
much public relations impact um so a one
sentence summary would be the condensed
matters the so-called sociology of
quantum objects you have a bunch of
small objects that obey quantum
mechanics that we think we understand
pretty well for instance like a bunch of
electron
or some ions that live in a crystal and
what's interesting about them is that in
their interactions with each other they
can give rise to new behavior that's
fundamentally different from the
small-scale behavior only like five ten
eight of them so these two pictures here
are actually pictures of two related
phenomena so on the right we have
something called bose-einstein
condensation where you have a huge
amount of very cold bosons which if you
cool them down enough they
macroscopically ie almost all the
particles in the system enter the lowest
energy state which has a bunch of
interesting quantum mechanical
properties that you can't observe
normally in a classical system which is
kind of surprising and on on your left
yeah we've got a superconductor which
again is like a fundamentally quantum
object so the reason this object is
levitating is because when its
constituent particles enter the lowest
energy state like occurs in that graph
on the right they can actually
experience what's called flux explosion
where you have a magnetic field that's
now forced out of the material and the
Scruton vector is able to quote levitate
this is also called the Meissner effect
if anybody's okay so the upshot is that
many quantum objects interacting with
each other can give rise to finally new
behavior and because it's new it's often
difficult for us to understand and so we
need some techniques to approach this
and because it's quantum mechanical it's
often unintuitive so why use a computer
understand this in some sense you don't
necessarily need to use a computer
people made a huge amount of progress
just with pen and paper techniques for
trying to understand the behavior of
millions of electrons for instance
interacting with each other in a crystal
but maybe if you're like me you're not
the best at sitting there you know
cranking out integrals all day so you
want to do something else and we know
that quantum states form vectors in a
hard space so they have some inner
product for our purposes it's a finite
size Hilbert space which is nice because
the bikers are a finite length and
usually because we're interested in
only a small portion of that hilbert
space for instance the low-lying states
and their excitations because that's
where we can observe quantum mechanical
phenomena we only really are interested
in a very small amount of the vectors
though of course it's usually not
particularly obvious which portion are
gonna give us the interesting physics so
we have a huge hilbert space in a very
tedious search problem and a series of
steps we can use to figure out if it
vectors interesting or not which is kind
of the perfect situation to use a
computer because then you know as I'm
sure many of you know in other data
science applications you kind of just
tell the computer what to do and then
get coffee for the next 50 hours and
then come back and front of your answers
wrong so very often in the quantum
mechanical context we spend a lot of our
time searching for a very very small
needle and a very very large haystack
just with the set of rules that's maybe
a little unintuitive to people more used
to dealing with regular data that's like
about human beings or objects which are
not car mechanical so as as point is
this what we want from a programming
language there's a couple things one of
the big ones is human efficient
parallelism by which I mean parallel
sort of kernels that are easy for human
beings to read and write and reason
about there's parallelism it's very
efficient for the computer to run but
it's very difficult for a human being to
understand what's going on for instance
if anybody's ever had to call MPI all
the LV you might know this pain so
there's a lot of different ways to set
up a massively parallel computation
across thousands of CPUs but we'd like
something that's easy for us to reason
about it's easy to write because again
most of the people doing quantum
mechanics on the computer went into
physics they didn't become CS majors and
so it's easier for them if we can have a
language with parallelism that's easy to
write we'd also like linear algebra as a
first-class citizen because that's kind
of the basic language of quantum
mechanics like I keep mentioning we want
something that's easy to write and teach
students and to our collaborators and
the upshot is that julia can do this
of course there are many other
situations where you might want to use
something else but a lot of us are using
Julia and trying to spin why
specifically what do I like it with
Julia did today when I'm doing research
so Julia was designed to do scientific
computing from day one all that you can
do things like write asynchronous Web
API is in it it was really designed from
the get-go for people like me who want
to do a huge amount of computation on
like giant linear algebra express models
um it's got a pretty diverse package
ecosystem for people who need things
like hdf5 which is a binary i/o flat so
you might have used which also supports
things like parallel i/o fast Fourier
transforms MPI first class or solving do
things like sundials and lots of other
packages they're really useful for
people doing either computational
science or data analysis and another way
of expressing that it sort of addresses
this two language problem is to say that
when I'm writing my simulation I can
write the model the parameter raised
that I want to examine for that model
for instance like couplings in the in
the energy function that describes the
physics I can write a job submission
script that will ask the nodes you know
please do this work for me
I can write past performance in
America's code to actually simulate the
physics I can analyze the data and plot
it all in one language and actually
sometimes even in one script file that
isn't 2,000 ones long which is pretty
great okay so for example part of my
research involves something called
tensor network methods where we try and
understand physics by examining the
couplings between local local matrices
or higher rank tensors and then optimize
those tensors to get a good picture of
what the ground state or other low
energy states might look like
um and so one thing that's great but
Julie is that you can just write high
rank tensors like rank six objects and
they just work they're indexed
efficiently it's great you can multiply
them slice them do it every one with
them which is really useful for us
because you don't have to reinvent the
wheel of test or operate
every time Julie also has really great
native distributed and shared memory
parallel ISM so for example if you're
running a computation across 10,000
notes each of which has 48 CPUs you want
to be able to up to spread information
among the notes which can't naively
access to each other's memory and then
within a node have the CPUs share the
local RAM which is also easy to do
inefficient both in terms of the actual
time performance and how long it takes
you to write the code which is important
giulia also supports from the get-go
really nice and easy unit testing
logging and documenting features and in
scientific code this is a big deal a lot
of scientific code really isn't unit
tested at all it's not very good there's
actually like a very famous situation
where there were about three or four
gold standard codes for a method and
people finally said you know we should
really run these and compare them on
like a very simple model and they did
and none of them gave the same answer
and everyone was like uh wait was it but
we've been using these to you know
solving these much more complicated
things where we really have no intuition
so which is right and I it was like a
ten year Odyssey of finding bugs amiss
and having easy unit testing is one way
to help people address this problem
because in many situations writing unit
tests is so painful that people won't do
it they'll agree you know I really
should be unit testing but they don't
want to because it's a real pain to both
write the tests and run them
Julia also has great logging and
documentation features which are again
very useful for scientific code
scientists are also not the best at
documenting code or keeping the
documentation up-to-date so being able
to do that right next to the code is
really really useful for us and then
finally Julia's type system lets us
express some of the concepts that are
useful for us in a variety of different
ways some which I will show you in a
second so for example there's gonna be a
lot of when you're asked for examples in
this so sorry if anybody here really
hates linear algebra if anybody here is
like a Galois Theory person I'm sorry
there's gonna be like none of that
so Julia supports a multiple dispatch
which of course the Python people is
probably pretty familiar so here we've
got an example where I want to compute
an Lu factorization for some matrix a
and of course a could be a variety of
different matrices it could be a sparse
type it could be just some sort of
regular old matrix which is expressed
this abstract array type maybe I want to
use pivoting maybe I don't which is what
a couple of these are we need the chance
to do the thing when I pass to the Lu
function could already be factorized in
which case I really don't have to do
anything or it could be a very simple
case where the thing I'm passing isn't
really a matrix at all it's just a
simple scalar which is also pretty
simple so what Julia will do is it'll
fall back to the correct specialized
method if I for instance I give it a
sparse type and if not they'll call the
generic method which won't repeat might
be a little bit slower but you don't
have to keep writing overloaded
operators for every single type you've
defined you can just simply fall back to
a generic provided your type has
indexing which again is probably pretty
familiar to you but this sometimes
freaks out people who are used to doing
linear algebra and like Fortran and it's
actually for us a very useful feature
because it makes our code a lot easier
to read so since we're talking about
linear algebra what specifically what
you need to do if you were doing physics
generically you need to do a lot of
operations on pretty small objects and
then a couple really costly operations
on very big objects for instance you
might if you're trying to solve a many
body quantum system need to diagonalize
a matrix that's like 2 to the 36 by 2
the 36 which is pretty big it's going to
be hard for you to do but then
constructing that matrix is going to
require you to do lots of small
operations on spot vectors so it's very
easy to use things like our PAC methods
which are probably familiar to people
who are used to doing numerical linear
algebra like eggs and SPD's but there's
also a nice ecosystem of packages that
let you do for instance subspace
iteration our other matrix right
operations in a parallel way the let's
you just call something that's been
optimized and it works really well it's
sort of continuing on the Lu example
julia has a really nice type annotation
system that's going to let us carry
around information about the matrix for
instance as we'll see on this slide you
can say you can inform Julia's type
system with what's called a type tag
that the matrix is hermitian and then
you can simply call the eigen solver on
it and it'll fall through to the correct
lapack method that calls the permission
eigen solver you don't have to remember
is it I exert ice age or a chives or
where is the H in this function name you
can just call eggs so here's an example
this is actually some code I have used
showing how Julius types work including
with the linear algebra so we're gonna
use the linear algebra part of Julius
standard library we're gonna define an
abstract type Hamiltonian which is like
a super type so the Hamiltonian is this
giant linear operator that describes the
interactions in the system and solving
it effectively gives you all the
information you need to figure out you
know is that what phases the system in
what is it what's its response to
perturbations if I smack it or get up so
if you've solved the Hamiltonian you've
solved everything basically many-body
quantum physics is a long career in
diagonalizing giant matrices so you've
got to be able to do this efficiently so
we create a super type or abstract type
Hamiltonian which has no members and
then we'll form subtypes of it or child
types which do have various attributes
but they'll all be able to use features
that the type system is aware of their
super abstract type Hamiltonian so for
instance Hamiltonians are always
permission because the eigenvalues of
the hamiltonian are the energies of the
various quantum states and energies
better be real numbers the eigenvalues
of a hermitian matrix are always real so
we can automatically say that any hand
looked anything that has a hamiltonian
type or a sub type information we can
tell the linear alkyl system how to
compute the eigenvalues
the Hamiltonian and then we can
construct a subtype so here we've got a
struct easing which is a subtype of the
Hamiltonian so the easy model is a very
famous and somewhat simple model for
quantum spin systems it has ground it
has various phases that represent either
a ferromagnet or a paramagnet depending
on the specific parameters that you have
it's also actually pretty related to UM
Conway's Game of Life if anybody's
familiar with that if you look it up
you'll see that the two of them are
pretty similar but it's basically the
simplest quantum model we can write down
and so we say that this thing is a
subtype of Hamiltonian it's got some
members each the actual matrix which is
hermitian so we feed that into the eigen
solver it's gonna correctly do the right
thing
deal with lapack for us we don't have to
worry some parameters J and little H
which control the couplings in the
system and the system size and then by
extending methods and Julia's base and
standard library we can easily feed
through our custom type into all of the
pre-built linear algebra architecture
which is really nice so in this toy
example I've constructed an easing
Hamiltonian I already know what the
matrix is and the coupling parameters I
asked is it hermitian yes it must be
because easing is a subtype of
Hamiltonian and I compute the
eigenvalues which are simply fed through
to the eigen solver this is a pretty
simple example because the matrix is
going to be diagonal but you can easily
imagine writing more complicated
constructors references you form the
matrix object yourself or you give it an
implicit function to compute matrix
vector products whatever um but from the
perspective of doing physics this is
really nice because it lets us easily
sort of organize our thoughts about the
relationships between different models
and also provide guarantees to the eigen
solver like this is hermitian or this is
if you wanted like a two-dimensional
three-dimensional model where there's
different rules about the the size of
the Hobart space or what's whether you
want to represent things as a an
explicit matrix or as a matrix vector
product or
other similar things okay so I mentioned
that julia has great testing this is an
example where again you just use the
test module we're testing some
properties about by diagonal matrices
here and you can organize things into
test sets you'd say like I want to test
everything about making a by diagonal
matrix which is a matrix where there's
the diagonal is filled in and then
either the the diagonal right above or
right below that is also filled so
there's some basic properties that
finish things should all obey by
diagonal matrices are always square and
if I put a vector on the upper diagonal
the lower one better be empty um and
what's nice about this is if one of
these tests fails Julia will say like
hey you had a failing test and it was
the constructor and basic properties
section so you don't have to go and like
dig through for line thousand 54 and
just kind of figure out what was in
there you can determine exactly what's
going wrong in your code and you can say
it was actually in the constructor basic
properties for the lower by diagonal
matrix rather than the upper one I don't
know how you did that wrong but somehow
you managed to do it wrong so fix it
other thing that's really nice is you
can combine this with documentation if
you wanted to document building a by
diagonal matrix you can actually include
an example as a dot test which when you
build the documentation will run and I
believe there are a bunch of Python
packages that have this - I think numpy
does this where when you build the dots
it'll make sure your example actually
works so you don't have a set of
documentation with examples for five
versions ago none of which run again
also a common problem in scientific
computing and this makes it really easy
to both document your code and for other
people to figure out how to use it and
it makes it seamless enough that it
actually encourages people to write
documentation because it's not that
useful as I'm sure many people here know
to have a documentation system if nobody
actually uses it there's sort of a
rubber hits the road factor of like if
if you build it will anybody come
the documentation system is only as good
as how much documentation people
actually write with it and the quality
of that documentation so Julia's system
makes it really really easy to produce
high-quality documentation with working
examples which is really a breath of
fresh air and a lot of computing code
for scientists especially because you
can do this for the numerical code
that's often difficult for people to
understand rather than just your
analysis code which was often the
situation previously okay so I mentioned
also that julia has great parallelism
there are varying degrees of control you
can have if you just want to call map
and just run a bajillion parameter
iterations that's fine you can totally
do that you can just call a parallel map
on some workers it's great so here I've
got an example where I construct matrix
a which is just some random numbers I
call a parallel map on it and what's
nice about this is the structure of the
input matrix will be preserved for
instance if I pass like a matrix of
parameters it'll come out and the same
format it went in and there's also a
bunch of packages that let us control
like the cluster you can just start
running a repple and allocate like a
thousand nodes and start queuing casts
on them but if you want maybe you're
more experienced or you really like
doing async for some reason you can also
set up your own parallel constructions
using like a sinks and futures and
channels if that's sort of more of the
paradigm you're coming from so if you
want finding fine-grained control you
can have it you don't need it to get
things done which is pretty great this
is a bit of a shout out to any hdf5
front fans here we use HD 5 which is um
a binary output format that you can call
in parallel pretty often the science
doing HD 5 io and C or C++ is maybe not
that great if anybody's used that API in
Python it's really great and Julie API
is quite similar to the one in Python it
makes doing high throughput i/o really
really easy and this is actually a great
example of how julia I think has really
benefited for
the existence of the Python community
because pythons been around so much
longer we've been really able to benefit
from the wisdom of people who've been
trying things seeing how well they work
for like twenty years so we can just
sort of a hijack their received wisdom
about what's the best way to represent
this operation use it and we can both
benefit from improved for instance I owe
both languages another thing that's
really great is we also have sort of
Jupiter notebook support the Ju in
Jupiter's for Juliet the PI obviously
and I guess the T is for Python and
there's a lot of really nice potting and
visualization packages it's not clear
that the community is entirely circled
on one which is great you can pick
whichever one you like so for example
this is a plot made in the latex potting
package PDF plots and because like in
Python Juliet codes aren't binary
they're really easy to port between
various systems like on Windows or on
you know the Linux cluster to your Mac
desktop or whatever and it's really easy
to do interoperability with Python or
Fortran or C there's a great package pi
called that JL which is looking for
contributors if anybody wants to
contribute which allows you to call
Python code very easily so for instance
it's really easy if you just like really
love mouth hot lib and you really want
to make matplotlib figures from Julia
it's extremely easy to do so if you are
interested in checking out some specific
things there's some research
publications that have been made with
Julia at this link if you are interested
in various science applications
celestial was I think the largest Julia
parallel run ever it was on this nurse
hopper supercomputer cost like ten
thousand nodes with some number of CPUs
each that does binary star
classification there's a Julia Astro
github organization there are quite a
few people working on biological
problems in Julia including the bio
Julia or got github for condensed matter
people if there's anybody else out there
you thought Hagerman tensor operations
jl is great or there's this quantum
optics package and another thing that
you can actually do in julia which i
think is now also possible in python
as well is you can write CUDA kernels
natively in the language we're sure
directly compiled by by LLVM to PDX
so you don't have to go through some
sort of weird sea middle layer you can
just directly write GPU code and finally
there are quite a few nice packages out
there for visualizing things or making
nice pots so some short takeaways are
that if you want to write very fast code
that's readable julia is definitely
something to consider the community is
really great it's both smart people who
are very kind
always interested in learning different
things our package ecosystem is growing
and getting better all the time there
are actually quite a few packages for
doing for instance like UI building or
web applications we also have a swift
wrapper if anybody wants to do Swift and
now that Julia 1.0 is out you can expect
a lot more stability in the language for
building packages off of or for working
on base itself and whether somebody is a
beginning programmer or experienced or
knows a lot of a Julia or nothing we
would be super excited to have you and
it pulsing hard so thanks everybody
thanks for your time and if you have any
questions feel free to ask I'm probably
going to be at the unconference at
various points whether your question is
about Julia or about some condensed
matter thing either it's fine and I'm
also doing the panel about first-time
open source contributing later today so
thanks for your attention
oh I thanks for the great talk now I
know a lot more about what Julia can do
can you tell me a few things that Julia
can't do that you'd like it to be able
to do particularly when considering like
the really large Python data science
stack that we have today yeah so I have
to give a caveat first which is I'm not
a data scientist so that part I may not
be able to address as well one thing I
will say that is very frustrating I said
although the plotting packages exist now
are like pretty good there definitely is
a lot of room for improvement there and
I if anybody watching this is a Julia
PLAs developer I said that in a loving
way but I think the plotting ecosystem
still has a ways to go
I would this was more of an issue before
1.0 came out but definitely stability
was an issue because things would break
every release and of course if you're
working in a company that's like not
probably acceptable for you you know if
your boss is like hey we need to run
this in production for five years and
you're saying okay cool but the next
release is gonna break everything in
three months so that's definitely also
not so awesome I would say from a from a
performance perspective Julia does have
some good performance analysis tools but
definitely the learning curve there is
quite steep so for your average person
trying to get started if their code is
slow it cannot it's not necessarily the
easiest thing in the world for them to
figure out why that is and Julia people
will say you know like oh well it's
inference
so just fix your types man and someone
who's starting out would be like okay
well that's cool but I don't know what
any of that means and then they're like
cool well just read this twenty pages of
documentation it's fine but that's not
fine because that person needs
performing code from the data science
perspective um so we do have our own
implementation of data frames and like
query and stuff like that but my sense
is that that's not as mature as it could
be and those people are still looking
for contributors but
see trying to think if it can think of
anything else today that's like a wish
list for things to get better especially
for the Sprint that's happening this
weekend
how about natural language processing
you can sort and the NLP I honestly
don't know very much about I can put you
in touch with someone who would who does
that like full-time yeah sorry no those
are great hands okay also just said that
people coming from the our ecosystem
have the same concerns about Python for
plotting and data visualization as well
I know they're accordions of several
plotting libraries here as well which
are great I just made eye contact with
one of them other questions done
sentence structure for the people in
academics don't really in line with
making really good code or documentation
or unit testing how do you get around
this to promote creating good code well
this is an opportunity for me to plug my
boss and employer the Flatiron Institute
so this is one of our missions is to
create open source codes like
specifically to create open source codes
for people in the sciences to use we're
trying it because as you said the
incentive structure has traditionally
not rewarded people who either develop
codes for people to use or approve
existing codes or for instance even like
write like write a bunch of notebooks
for people to learn from that's not
rewarded because it doesn't necessarily
result in publications
so part of what Flatiron is trying to do
is pay people to do this in a way where
they have some job security and they
could say you know I'm gonna devote five
years to building a better code to
achieve this um but in general you know
obviously I mean I like where I work and
they're wonderful but not everybody on
earth is gonna be employed there I think
in general we need to
a way to sort of acknowledge people's
contributions in the form of packages
for instance I think there's now a way
to do I your package which is great and
then of course there's a cultural issue
you have to get people to recognize you
know I cited this package and that was a
lot of work so that person deserves some
credit you know when they're being hired
or they're on a tenure committee or
something so some of it is I think we
need to have a way to communicate to
people who are not as immersed in the
open-source ecosystem of like you know
there's this piece of work that exists
that invests it that represents some
extent of like personal effort and then
some form of review in the sense that
other people will you know use the code
and submit issues and stuff which isn't
exactly the same thing as what you know
journal articles consider peer review
but it is a form of peers who are
reviewing your work and there needs to
be a way to give credit to that person
and then there's the separate cultural
issue of convincing senior people in the
field people making hiring decisions and
you know this is very valuable work here
all the knock-on effects the
publications that were enabled by it and
convincing those people will be helped
if you can cite you know the package or
whatever but in terms of like actually
arguing human beings into taking open
source contributions we're seriously
that I'm not so sure how to do because
I'm often not very good at arguing
anything at senior people so maybe
somebody with more more natural language
processing or social psychology
expertise should take that but the
vendor your question okay thank you
so I noticed that there was reference to
type inference and I was just a little
curious about the type system of Julie
do you find that it can kind of get in
your way like some of the more esoteric
functional languages is it very
unobtrusive do you have to specify a lot
of types for best performance what is
the situation with the type system and
Julia this is
this is kind of a compliment answer I
would say that personally I find the
type system helpful because I think of
it as a way of specifying a series of
constraints or promises because I
there's only one level of type hierarchy
so in Juliette you have these abstract
super types and then things can be
subtypes of them but only to one degree
so for instance if I go back to example
come on where are you okay so in this
example right we had easing which is a
subtype of Hamiltonian so I couldn't
define something that's then again a
subtype of easing so there's only one
level of hierarchy which prevents you
from getting into those C++ like like
virtual class destructor hell if anybody
also has had that experience in C++
so in the sense that if you use the type
system as a series of guarantees or
promises that like this will always be
hermitian
this has indexing or for instance does
not have indexing this is or is not a
number or this is or is not made up only
of numbers or only of strings I don't
find the type system particularly
obtrusive and it's also like helpful for
for me reasoning to say you know like
these are the rules about what this kind
of object can do or what things I'm
allowed to do to it in terms of
performance um probably one of the
biggest performance gotchas in julia is
so the cloudy sort of foggy phrase type
issues whenever the type system has to
figure out or has to perform inference
to figure out for instance like if i'm
adding an object that's an integer and
an object that's a 32-bit float what's
the correct type for the result to be
that's something that the type system
has to do and you can provide hints to
it to say like it should always be this
type like this larger type but if you
don't provide the hint then you'll often
have serious performance problems
especially if you know you're in an
inner loop because over and over again
the type system has to determine oh this
should be like a much bigger float or
something like that so there are ways to
figure out where this system is spending
time particularly if it's a sort of type
inference issue to say like okay what
should the resulting type of this
operation be but like I mentioned
earlier it can be annoying for people
who are new to figure out how to
determine I have a tie problem where is
it happening why is it happening how do
I fix it
so this is definitely I think an area
where we could improve if you're if
you've been using Giulia for a while
it's not really a problem because you've
had to do it a bunch of times but
definitely the first couple of instances
you have to figure out why is my loop so
slow oh my gosh and then you realize
it's a type inference issue I've
definitely seen a lot of people who are
newer to the language sort of sit there
looking at it and be like uh I don't
know what to do now can you help me
which we're happy to do but it would be
great if they could instead say okay
here's the documentation it's really
easy for me to figure out how to
identify this and how to fix it so
hopefully that will be coming more with
1.0 if anybody from juliek computing is
watching this please did that answer
your question
anybody cats out of the room I have a
question
so as an undergraduate I spent a few
months involved in high energy physics
research and there was always this
ongoing debate between C or C++ and
Python things like real programmers
right see you know um so my question is
um how widely used is julia within the
physics community and are there specific
subfields within physics for which it's
better suited um this is kind of hard to
answer because first i have i don't know
every physicist on earth and I know you
wouldn't expect me to be like all right
I called everybody 15,000 people
answered but I would say it's very
variable by field so for instance one of
the areas I do research in tensor
networks which is actually an area with
some crossover between high energy
physics which for people who don't know
high energies like what you think of
when you think of particle physics or
stuff that happens at the LHC there's
connections to cosmology there's
actually a lot of connections between
that and
and then spider physics and one of the
ways that's expresses with sensor
networks so a lot of people in the
tensor number community are like really
into Julia we're actually planning to
port
one of the main libraries we use from
C++ to Julia or at least write a wrapper
which is really exciting
but the tensive network community isn't
huge and there's lots of other areas of
condensed matter physics where people do
numerix that I like basically don't ever
talk to so one problem I think in the
academic physics community is that
there's definitely not enough sort of
crosstalk or between different areas of
physics which is something that we
should working improve on so it's kind
of hard to answer how much are people
using Julia I do think though that it's
pretty well suited to like a variety of
different problems like obviously I use
it for research so I think it's great
for condensed matter I know there are
quite a few astronomers using it by
subfield that was strong and like I
don't know if the solar system people
have like different opinions than the
stellar structure people I think they
have different needs and I think they're
also like some some people in in the
lattice gauge Theory community which is
a kind of Monte Carlo for anybody who
hasn't heard this other annoying piece
of jargon there's a lot of jargon in
this field but I think it yeah the
different subfields of physics are
actually like in some ways very siloed
so it's hard to answer but I do think if
you need letting your algebra or
parallelism or good IDE support it's a
good option and then I guess the other
thing is I'm just just to address maybe
something that was implicit in the start
of your question one thing I do like a
lot about the joy of communion I think
many parts of the Python community too
is people are trying to get away from
this like real programmers do X sort of
thinking we're like really I think a
good attitude that a lot of people have
is real programmers write programs that
work and are maintainable which is it
sounds like a cytology but I think it's
a bit like saying like real writers
actually sit down and write like it's
very easy to sit around like arguing
about like oh do real programmers do
this or that but at the end of the
real judgment is you have working code
that other people can use and maintain
that produces decent results okay then I
don't have to like try and fight you
about like well you word it this way or
this other way or in this language of
that language and definitely a good
experience I've had talking to people
especially people in the Python
community who are scientists is that
they're like oh you like this well
that's great what do you like about it
and then we have a conversation then
they say well I'm gonna stick with
Python because it's working for me and
the Julie people like yeah that's cool
awesome if you ever want to tell you
what Julia come see me but otherwise
like good luck with your paper and it's
just it's a good atmosphere like people
supporting each other and trading ideas
so I hope there'll be more that in the
future so yeah
so that was a very long answer of an
answer your question all right let's
give you like two seconds to see if
there's any less questions but if not
all right oh thank you
[Music]
you